a high school English teacher in
Missouri named Brianna copage was placed
on leave earlier this month and quickly
resigned from her position after as the
media reports put it she was outed as a
performer on only fans and of course the
word outed is doing a lot of work here
so is the word performer she is a
prostitute not a performer and she outed
herself when she decided to engage in
this behavior on the internet where
anyone in the world can see it for a
small subscription fee now I must again
remind everyone that you have not been
outed when people simply notice what you
yourself have decided to post on the
internet as soon as something is on the
internet it is out it is as out as a
thing can possibly be the outing
occurred the moment it was posted and if
it was posted by you then you again
outed yourself that's not how Brian
copage sees it though uh she has
defended herself to the local media
here's what she says a former teacher in
the Metro speaks only to locally to to
four about being outed for bearing it
all when that Franklin County woman's
only fans page was found she was pulled
from the classroom then Brianna copage
voluntarily resigned and tonight only AR
shash stall has the first interview with
the teacher turned entrepreneurial porn
star it's just like those connections
that I'm going to miss Brianna copage
started teaching 5 years ago being there
for students like celebrating Milestones
with them for the last 2 years and until
resigning earlier this month she was at
St Clair high school as an English
teacher and one reason for her departure
to make more money she started an only
fans page a site that's growing popular
across many generations on only fans
some offer premium content to build
connections with subscribers such as
inspirational speeches photos and even
adult
content okay time out for a second why
are we playing dumb about only fans here
what what what what are you trying to
achieve the local CBS affiliate is
pretending for some reason that people
go to only fans for inspirational
speeches maybe that's the excuse the
reporter's husband gave her when she
found out about his subscription to the
site no honey it's it's not what it
looks like I I'm just subscribed for the
inspirational speeches it's kind of the
new generations version of I only read
Playboy for the Articles and that could
be where this is coming from or maybe
they're just randomly lying about only
fans because the media reflexively lies
about everything and can't help itself
at this point in any case here's what
Briana um has to say for herself listen
Missouri is one of the lowest States in
the nation for teacher pay and then the
district I was working for is also one
of the lowest paying districts in the
state copage says her yearly teaching
salary was
$42,000 when she started only fans she
avoided showing her face because of her
job as a teacher a lot of people asking
why didn't you just get like a part-time
job somewhere but teachers also take all
of their work home like we don't get to
stop working when we leave the school
day we don't get to grade all 130
students papers during the day it's just
not possible when you're teaching so we
take that work home with us on the
evenings on the weekends so getting a
second job is just really not possible
the St Clair School District said in a
statement it was notified of the posts
by an individual not affiliated with the
school the statement goes on to say the
district immediately retained legal
counsel for assistance due to the
sensitivity of the matter and to protect
the Integrity of the investigation our
handbook policies are very vague they
just say something about like represent
yourself
well did I violate that I feel like
that's a matter of
opinion uh yes ma'am you did violate
that it's actually not vague at all I
suppose there could be some gray area in
the represent yourself well category but
when you start selling your body on the
internet you have definitely crossed
over the line not just crossed it but
you've trampled it into dust becoming an
only fans prostitute is the very
definition of not representing yourself
well if the district needs to clarify
that section of the handbook then they
they should do it by adding a picture of
Briana copage a fully clothed picture
just just to be clear Rihanna defends
her decision to become as the news
anchor puts it an entrepreneurial porn
star by saying that well she wants to
she makes a lot of money doing it which
I'm sure she does but the problem is
that I make a lot of money doing this is
the worst possible moral justification
for
anything okay many of the bad things
people do do because they make money
doing it but we don't accept that as an
excuse if someone says you know you know
accuses you of engaging in objectionable
and immoral behavior and you respond but
I make a lot of money doing it they
generally aren't going to say oh okay
well never mind then I mean obviously
it's totally acceptable in that case I
just want to make sure that you weren't
behaving in a disgusting and shameful
way for free but as long as you're
making money then never mind carry on
that's not how the conversation goes and
that's because we know you're doing it
for money and attention and validation
but that doesn't make it better now if
this story sounds familiar it's because
a version of this story plays out
seemingly like once a week now before
Brianna copage it was a woman named
Annie Knight who made some headlines
after getting fired from her corporate
marketing job after starting an only
fans page before her it was Kristen
McDonald who's the special needs
teaching assistant who was fired after
her only fans activities were discovered
and it's not just teachers and employees
in the corporate world getting fired for
this a while ago a female mechanic at a
Honda dealership in Indiana was also
fired from her job when she began
dabbling in the entrepreneurial porn
business and so this sort of thing
happens frequently and for the most part
these women when they're fired are
treated as Martyrs by the media but they
are not Martyrs it goes without saying
or should go without saying that all of
these women deserve to be fired your
employer is concerned not just with your
behavior at work but also with your
behavior outside of work if it reflects
poorly on them or causes difficulties in
the workplace your employer has a right
to take those kinds of things into
consideration which means that if you
become a prostitute in your free time
you should absolutely lose your job you
know most people don't want to work with
or around prostitutes and your employer
doesn't want to employ prostitutes it's
disgraceful and dirty and disgusting and
embarrassing this is obviously
especially the case if you're a teacher
but it applies no ma no matter your
occupation
and yes as established only fans is
prostitution as I've been arguing for
years all pornography is prostitution to
be a prostitute is to sell your body for
money and that's what everyone in the
porn industry is doing it's what
everyone on only fans is doing it's what
a hooker on the street corner is doing
there is no moral difference or even any
significant practical difference between
any of these categories but with only
fans as opposed to what I guess we must
call traditional internet porn this
equivalency is the most
obvious you know that that only fans is
like the most direct parallel with being
a hooker on a street corner which is
also why only fans should obviously be
banned now I think all pornography
should be banned but if we have to go
about this incrementally then only fans
is a very good place to start the
October 15th tax deadline has come and
gone I know many of you might be
dreading the stress of filing your taxes
filing your taxes can be a long
excruciating process but if you fail to
file you start to pile penalties on your
tax debt that's why you need to check
out tax Network USA the team at tax
Network USA has a track record of
success they've reduce tax debt for
numerous clients totaling over $1
billion whether you're looking at a
$10,000 or a $1 million tax debt they
can help you with a settlement it
doesn't matter if you haven't filed in
one year five years even a Whole Decade
tax Network USA is equipped to secure
the best settlement for you the expert
attorneys and tax professionals at tax
Network USA can help resolve all tax
cases no matter how they started don't
let tax debt control your life any
longer take the first step toward
resolving your tax issues by visiting
tax Network
usa.com Walsh that's tax Network
usa.com Walsh today you know the tragedy
of only fans and this is not to say that
these women's these women are victims of
of their own choices because because
these are their choices but the tragedy
is that nearly all of these only fans
prostitutes would not be prostitutes if
only fans didn't
exist these like soccer moms and English
teachers and corporate professionals
they wouldn't ever even consider going
out to the street corner to turn tricks
nor would they go looking for a gig at
the strip club down the street what
they're doing on the site is morally and
substantively and should be considered
legally the same because there's no real
distinction but the presence of the
screen the fact that it's all done in
cyers space makes it feel different you
know it allows prostitutes to feel like
they are not
prostitutes and that's why they're
invariably shocked when they end up
getting fired from their respectable
jobs I don't think that shock is like a
put on they aren't pretending to be
surprised they really bought into the
LIE of only fans and of the internet
pornography business as a whole and
believed that because they were doing
this on the internet it somehow didn't
count in the real
world only fans makes a life of
prostitution accessible for people who
would never consider it otherwise now
that's not to say that bana uh and all
the bana cages of the world would be
virtuous chased dignified women if not
for only fans it's only to say that they
would not be call girls whoring
themselves out for $10 a month only fans
makes that possible in a unique way
which is why it should not be allowed to
exist it is a universal
negative it hurts everybody involved in
it
it harms Society it can only cause harm
there is no counterbalancing good being
done by
it prostitution is already illegal in 49
out of 50
states the question is whether there
should be this carve out this special
privilege granted to internet
prostitution but why should there be why
is there in fact internet prostitution
has a more deleterious effect because of
its accessibility and its ubiquity
because it's the one kind of
prostitution that a board soccer mom
would actually engage in so if we're
only Banning one type of prostitution
the inperson or Internet
variety obviously it should be the
latter but instead we ban the former and
the ladder is legal and virtually
unregulated it makes no
sense only fans in conclusion is a
cancer it should be banned and it
certainly today is is cancelled if You'
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed